міста ви було вхід пий
ми продовжимо у нашої дискусії ще дані
ви вирішених конфлікті у всьому світити
починаючи сказавши сирі та україні кндр.
in countless ви чайну на контролі
ванну в похмуру я хочу так можна вислати
еся е наша трансатлантичним проти
такої не ви значущості зробили різанини
заява цей вид з вашингтону та walking
інституті кадр та слабину мінським
домовленостям двору клмн і ту ж
просунулась у тему на премію
переговори від ремонт новий імпульс їх
рахунок США про і знаєте так ти хто б
рятували дні за гієною упор щуках мирного
ви вирішення конфлікту вливаємо півсклянки
гречки я пропливав адміністрації трампу
вимовляючи до нормандського формату
владикам туди Росії та Франції не меч він
це владні україни україни
it-sales.com.ua переговорний формат
айфона та ояки наші назад і 1000 зал 100
не п'єте рокки у міжнародній сфері
нота провалила вся випробувай по клас ти
край крила та катастрофічні winews ірії
ларі як назвати і чим же ти року вигляд
буваєте в Україні дві тисячі людей
вибуття то сотні тисяч на витрачання ви свої
будиночки я як диво теперішні провини і
часу конфлікту комусь менших місцях
у свиті по але я хаос рада сході він
розколоте назад на хвалю від рішення у
звити серйозні проблеми і тут же тут
на заході
з шато їх не європейські партнери
стікаються з таким видом центровим із села
ми зараз ситуація з правдиві ікла я
був і cutter вову
ціни хороший рік для миру та стабільності
у світлі